[Music]
macpat
back for more eh i thought you had had
enough after all that princess nonsense
you're right mickey i may have already
proven that you're a hypocrite cashing
in on women's empowerment but this time
i'm out to go one
step further i'm out to show the world
that you're not just a money grubber but
also that you are one murderous
mouse but we produce family-friendly
movies matpat
totally brand friendly tell that to the
victims in your movies
oh yeah and how many people have i
killed then matpat
10 20 a few hundred a few thousand
how many my pet how many victims are
there in my movies
calculate that one if you're so smart i
dare you
hello internet welcome to film
theory call us detective pikachu because
we're solving the mysteries
you didn't ask about and might not have
actually wanted to know about
like our episode on wall-e where i
talked about the fact that everyone is a
cannibal or all those theories about
child murder ah those are good ones to
catch up on with your hot cocoa during
these lazy holidays and hey while
everyone else is starting their holidays
early i'm still gung-ho about giving you
a present a present of film theory
specific merch being available for the
first time
ever right now film theory hoodies and
socks they're warm they are super high
quality with embroidered patterns and
patches
into the fabric and they're available
for delivery and time for christmas if
you order in the next few days
we'll know that theaters are way too
cold show everyone in the theater that
you're proud to overanalyze what you're
seeing up on screen
and that you're staying warm and snuggly
in the process links are in all the
places you would expect those links to
be come on this is youtube it is not
your first time at the rodeo you know
how this works but that's not the only
present i'm getting you for the holidays
this year i'm also giving you the gift
of ruined
childhood classics so strap in for a
particularly stabby one today
quite honestly over the next couple
weeks because i'm starting in on what's
turning out to be one of the most
monumental feats of my entire film
theory career
i am dissecting every major disney movie
that means every disney animated film
that's been in theaters since 1939 to
determine once and for all
which is the deadliest of all the disney
movies
and if i can swing it what is the
overall total kill count for the entire
disney canon and boy it is
so much harder than it looks in case you
haven't noticed over the years
disney movies for all their cute talking
animals can get surprisingly
dark and the characters are pretty darn
good at killing one another and in some
really creative ways too
i mean clayton and tarzan hanging
himself with the vine
oliver and companies electrocution by
subway track some of this stuff is
better than the slasher movies that you
see in deadmeat's kill count
series i mean sure some disney movies
only manage light emotional scarring
but when you start dealing with dragons
snow monsters and very sharp sewing
equipment
[Music]
you start running into some serious
collateral damage in a hurry
but just how much are we talking about
well it is
way more than you'd think especially
considering that this lineup is all g
or pg rated and intended for kids but
looking across all of disney's history
across its 60 disney animation studio
theatrical releases i'm aiming to find
out where the mouse is not just killing
it at the box office but also
literally killing everyone you see on
screen and if you think this is just a
matter of a little counting here and
there you are
solely mistaken there is so much more
here than meets the eye as evidenced by
the fact that i thought this was just
gonna be one straightforward episode and
has now blown up into a three episode
mini saga through the depths of the
disney catalog covering everything from
the ecology of the pacific islands to
the biology of the african serengeti to
the ancient history of the grecian isles
oh yeah we are going thorough with this
one i'm telling you now by the end of
this little mini series you are going to
be struggling to crawl out from under
the heaps of animated bodies
piled up on top of you so what is the
deadliest disney movie
place your bets now and see if you're
right at the end i don't know you can
make a little bet about it with your
family or whoever you feel comfortable
talking about this topic with hey mom
and dad what do you think the deadliest
disney movie is bet you
five bucks it's meet the robinsons don't
do that that would be a stupid
stupid bet spoiler alert it is not meet
the robinsons like i said
approaching the concept of the most
deadly disney movie is deceptively
complicated take for instance
this rabbit this rabbit and this rabbit
they're all the same animal across three
different movies but would you count
them all in a death total if they died
one is the white rabbit from alice in
wonderland one is thumper from bambi
and one is just i guess like one of snow
white's supportive woodland friends
they're all alive they're all cute
bunnies but for the purposes of this
theory
they don't all count and this is where
we have to lay ourselves some ground
rules
should we count the rabbit who carries a
pocket watch because he's wearing people
clothes what about the one who defends
bambi in his time of crisis
for this theory i drew the line around
sentience versus
nonsentience of the character's deaths
one thing that's
really obvious in disney movies is that
different species may or may not be
sentient in any given movie
usually humans or at least humanoids
take the spotlight but in movies like
the lion king
animals are the focus they are clearly
sentient and most importantly for our
purposes
they can speak so let's just set the
rule if animals can speak
or if they act as intentionally driven
characters like maleficent's pet raven
diablo then they count in our overall
death total we also can't extrapolate
beyond the actions taken in the movie
that we're watching did the colony
established by john smith eventually go
on to kill thousands of natives in the
1995 pocahontas
yeah absolutely but that doesn't happen
during the run time of the movie because
we can't have that punky white guy lose
right
so he gets a pass at least in this
context history would beg to differ
and finally we can only count kills that
are actually caused by the characters in
the movie for example
in hercules we can't count the actions
taken off screen by hades in his normal
role as god of death since he's just
presiding over the people who are dying
as usual
instead we can only count the actions he
takes directly against hercules and the
other gods also guys
no sequels there is nothing less
satisfying than coming out at the end of
one of these really long analyses
only to find out that cinderella 3 a
twist in time actually kills the most
people because it creates this time
paradox that threatens to destroy
cinderella and her entire kingdom
that takes ralph breaks the internet and
rescuers down under off the table yeah
just take my word for it guys we're all
dodging a bullet by sticking only to the
original
in theater releases we're already
covering 58 other movies
these are long episodes so maybe if you
like this concept we can do another
tournament of
the sequels or pixar movies or whatever
just
later i need a disney break after this
one so with our handy-dandy rule book
established we're ready to face death
head-on
or at least in our disney movies our
first task is to carve up our 58
contender movies into more manageable
categories to see who has a fighting
chance
or should i say a dying chance of
claiming the ultimate title
disney's deadliest movie if you look
across the spectrum from 1939 to today
you'll see
that these movies fall into a few pretty
distinct categories when it comes to
death you have no death movies
single or double death movies low kill
count movies and then you have
the really heavy hitters there aren't
too many mid-level death movies in
disney's
canon surprisingly you're either all in
on the murder or you're not and you're
questionably family friendly our job is
to figure out who's in that last
category and then suss out who's the
biggest offender from the last 80 years
of filmography
starting at the very beginning there is
a whole slew of movies in the disney
canon where the kill count is either
zero or just a really low number movies
like dumbo the jungle book sword and the
stone and 101 dalmatians are all
no kill movies
as our robin hood and the feature films
of winnie the pooh in our no kill films
the antagonist is usually thwarted in
some comedic way and then just
kinda gives up their evil plot cruella
deville from 101 dalmatians
car wreck and just gives up also while
we're talking about it i'd be remiss if
i didn't play this gem of a line from
101 dalmatians
crazy woman driver it's great
old school disney was so inappropriate
shere khan from the jungle book also
fire on tail just gives up or quite
frankly there's just not enough movie
there to have time to kill anyone else
man a lot of these movies are a lot
shorter than i remember
what's that one supposed to mean you ask
well i'm talking about the disney movies
you probably haven't seen or even
heard about from disney's forgotten
decade the 1940s
the reason it's the forgotten decade is
probably because during the 1940s a
large portion of disney's writing and
animation staff were drafted into world
war
ii sometimes leaving their stories half
done or half animated and making it
necessary for whoever was left in the
studio to cobble together a feature film
from whatever was left the movies that
came out during this time
kind of had plots they had little to no
dialogue and are sometimes even just
repurposed pieces of animation that were
left over from other movies while
everyone else was out supporting the war
effort this is why so many of these no
kill movies are musical reviews
featuring questionable live-action
segments of donald duck sexually
harassing women and totally
uncomfortable race relations
it's interesting to note here too that
the drafted disney animators weren't
trading in their pens for guns they
weren't out on the front lines fighting
they were actually still wielding their
animator pencils
they were still developing films using
the exact same skills they used at
disney only now they were drafted into
making propaganda films for the war
effort in fact if you want a really
fascinating watch check out victory
through airpower an official disney
release that outlines the history of air
combat which in and of itself is
fascinating but also was one of their
first major propaganda films meant for
public consumption i just
didn't include it in the overall kill
count since you know it's world war ii
there were a lot of deaths but they were
historically accurate deaths
it's just a fun fact that i came across
while i was researching for this episode
and i thought you might enjoy but it
also explains why you don't see a lot of
full character arcs or
deaths during the films from this time
period it also makes you look at
propaganda films
and disney movies just a little bit
differently probably merits a theory for
another day regardless for as short
boring and culturally inappropriate as a
lot of these might be
for this theory i'm digging up all the
skeletons of the past and need to know
whether anyone dies in disney features
like the three caballeros and fun and
fancy free
and holy shattered childhood some of
these movies are
shockingly brutal while most of them do
rack up zero kills you have yourself
some horrific surprises
like make mine music where a whale whose
only goal
in life is to sing at the opera gets
himself harpooned
to death in a mistake and takes four
sailors down in the process
also a wolf dies so that one has a total
of six or you have melody time where we
see the story of little toot who
honestly should be renamed big
body count after his pranks decimate a
giant tanker
and an entire city block that's a body
count in the double
if not triple digits next there's also a
slew of movies where only the head
villain gets the axe or
just the head villain in like one or two
other people he kills during his first
scene of the movie just to show how evil
of a villain he is
in these cases they've already shown
themselves to be 100 irredeemable so you
don't have to feel badly about their
gruesome grotesque murder
snow white only the evil queen dies
sleeping beauty maleficent and her
underling raven diablo
lady and the only kills a rat but
remember it counts because it's a movie
filled with sentient animals the
rescuers have medusa who is just a
recycled version of cruella de vil the
great mouse detective has a ratigan and
underling and two of his henchmen and
peter pan loses two pirates
surprisingly not captain hook so yay
despite the fact that there's still like
dozens of other murderous pirates
running around neverland and also
killer mermaids if you know the source
material other notable mentions from
this category snow white singing
with a smile
all your cares fly away right after her
attempted murder like i've heard of the
power of positive feelings but
geez you might want to take a couple
minutes and process what just happened
to you snowy also coming from the
dishonorable mentions of this 60 movie
spree
fantasia 2000 which only has one death a
shockingly handsy jack-in-the-box
but also features the single most absurd
moment in all of disney animated canon a
sequence of donald duck
on board noah's ark like two by two
animals and then there's just
donald duck noah literally reaches out
to donald ducks and come come aboard my
biblical ark
what that's already after you've had
scenes of flying whales and pen and
tellers cringy magic hand bits i mean if
you have never seen fantasia 2000 this
movie is like
the hottest of hot messes last things to
call out here real quick because i know
i'm going to hear about them in the
comments tangled
yes we see a huge dam break but it's in
a secluded area of the wilderness and
everyone swept away by the water
ultimately resurfaces later so there's
only one death there and that's mother
gothel at the end
also wreck-it ralph forced me to think
through my rules since we see
thousands of cyborgs die but remember
they're not sentient so they don't count
also we see sergeant calhoun's husband
die in a flashback but remember she is
just video game code meaning that her
husband never
actually existed as a program in the
system so only one death there which is
the big bad of turbo who died in a video
game that wasn't his and therefore he is
just
outright dead no more continues for him
telling up the disney films with just a
single digit death toll gives us 41
which leaves us 17 left to cover
but this is where things start to get
difficult it seems like it should be
just an easy task to go through and
count dead bodies but in a number of
these cases the analysis
starts to get pretty complex like frozen
we see anna and elsa's parents
die in a shipwreck but how many actually
bit the dust in that scene i mean sure
we see a third person welcoming them
on board the ship but clearly there
needs to be more crew on here than just
him when you do the research
technically there's probably about 33
deaths
total in frozen obviously the parents
and marshmallow who does count because
if olaf dies you would probably count
him so marshmallow should also count but
also there's the crew of
30 people that it would take to man a
hulk ship of that size from that era and
that's just the tip of the iceberg how
about
bambi how do you calculate how many
woodland creatures die in that movie's
forest fire how about how many antelope
deaths is scar responsible for in the
lion king that fulfills all our rules
how many huns did mulan kill how many
lives did ursula destroy in her little
mermaid typhoon at the end
the answers involve a mix of history art
and computer science
so stick around because who makes it to
the deadly finish line and how we crown
the winner is likely to be a bit
surprising the next episodes are already
written and ready to go but in the
meantime you should let me know which
movie you think is going to come out on
top in the comments the next part should
be out in just a few days
i know i know it's a cliffhanger you can
murder me in the comments it'll just add
one more to that kill count
i am slaying myself over here you see
now you want me to stop
so until next time remember that's just
a theory
a film theory and
cuts
[Music]
you